[Music]
and welcome to terms of the week
grandmaster Dennis Porsche and we're
going to look through games of legend
legend
it's just seen just a second ago
probably maybe you haven't but now
you're gonna make that up as this event
play for Russia of certain legend was
playing and he was Vladimir Kramnik and
what is actually fascinating and these
games that he played that he just goes
through all his phases so he plays
positionally then back to tactics stand
back to positional chest you never know
what's going on so in this lecture we're
going to figure out which kramnik are we
watching at the moment so with that
let's get started with this game between
kramnik versus napalm Miyaichi the
current candidates player who's still
playing technically in the candidates
yet the candidates is all a hold the
permanent hold you shall see all right
so this game was played between
kramnik and the candidates nappa
Miyaichi who's actually at the
leaderboard up there so c4 c5 g3 and
this is considered to be a slightly
sleepy / boring opening however
in this variation Geary couldn't breach
napalm the Archies defenses not only
that now promenade she even won that
game that actually catapulted him into
the leaders but back to this game
probably Kramnik wanted to play as solid
as possible just going against Napoli
Archie's urge to get complications g6
Bishop g2 Knight c3 Knight c6 e 3e six
now if you know chronics affection for
smith sloven his games you will guess
his next move and if you don't know
Smith's love you'll never guess it so
I'm just gonna show it on the board
it's b3 why is this such a big thing
well Smith stove really like the double
fianchetto and kramnik as a big fan of
Smith's love wanted to try it out as
well so the point of b3 is the following
so in a beautiful world I'm just making
some random moves here white could go
ahead try to exchange this Bishop on g7
and still have an unopposed bishop on g2
that is in general the essence of
chronics plan but instead here
b3 97 he plays Bishop a3 which is a very
exciting move by Kramnik he's actually
moving it all the way to a 3 instead of
b2 which would be a bit more logical
however he has a plan in mind
b6 92 castle castle this should be 7 and
here he gets to play d4 which he
couldn't play if the bishop was on b2
because he wouldn't win at the time and
he wouldn't have pressure on the c5 pawn
again this is the typical positional
chronic that we see here he's trying to
end
ever so close to glory and in this case
he actually gets a little bit of a push
why because most sides have these
bishops fianchettoed Napo has those
bishops on b7 and g7 why does so that
would even out
however the dis bishop lurking on a3
there are certain threats after let's
say C takes he takes d4 this bishop will
immediately put pressure on blacks
position and if d5 and oftentimes c5
would be an alternative and with this
bishop being stronger than the b7 one
might can hope for in a little advantage
even that some of this b4 b5 stead Napo
plays d6 but these six actually invites
a structure that we can only describe as
tears that is the Benoni and if you ask
any grandmasters or anyone who ever
watched a broadcast of a candidates
tournament you'd know it's not a fun
thing to play and it only leads to
suffering
therefore the tears so Queen d2 and here
Napo plays Knight a5 which is an
interesting idea trying to get sort of a
Hedgehog type of position and trying to
hold that position but Kramnik being
very well aware that this is a Benoni
structure he is just eager to play d5
right there he takes C takes d5 Bishop
a6 so this is by the way one of the
worst type of beninese the bishop is
already on b7 where it's not supposed to
be it's supposed to be on d7 and there's
a knight on a five on the ramp
just acting Grem not a good thing just
all those guys lurking around in the
corner not doing so hot so here let's
try to find Kramnik next move for the
moment we can say Dwight is doing
alright more than alright because he has
control over the center and potentially
can get even more pawns right there and
the side pawn with f4 however you still
need to be accurate in this game of
chess if you ever hope to get an
advantage so let's try to find out what
was cram mix next move the viewers
let's get thinking so first off you
always have to check for threats and
they're plenty now neppo is famous for
being an aggressive player so there are
plenty of threats there threats on e 2
and threats on the knight on c3 and even
after Bishop e2 92 there's a bishop
takes a 1 now that's not the exchange
you dream about but it is an exchange so
noticing these type of threats that
actually might guide you towards the
best move which was actually played by
kramnik
I see rook e1 suggested I do not know
which rook though if you could pinpoint
which one would you want to play that'd
be great
before however before could run in
tonight see for ideas and suddenly this
terrible Bishop becomes a real ninja
bothering both the bishop and the Queen
and in fact black is the one who's
calling the shots
the Afric so the problem that rook F e1
that you still didn't solve Bishop takes
ethos problem and your work on Amon
would be hanging somebody was mentioning
there should be two and indeed and this
is again typical Grandmaster play they
sends danger and they stopped it before
it ever happens so not only did he get
this Bishop to b2 he might even get
Knight e4 in there and tried to put
pressure along the diagonal and again is
the same game plan for white here you
have a good fee enchanted Bishop
exchange off this guy on g7 and you are
guaranteed to have an advantage so
realizing that this Bishop is not that
great Napo - Connie - takes Knight f5
and again here comes the big question
should we continue
should we take on g7 should we wait with
that rook C 1 that is a very natural
move it doesn't do much however you do
bring and develop your rooks into the
game a decent enough move however let's
try to find something even stronger
so in the opening you still fight for
something called the center and the more
of you get it the happier you get really
it's like chocolate cake if you get more
of it you'll be super happy
the less you get the more unhappy the
whole day will get II for indeed now II
for here is actually the most accurate
move now you might want to take on g7
first however this has a downside
because if you Blake we be to now
then black can go Queen f6 and after
these exchanges black might get some
counter play with b5 c4 so e4 is the
most accurate because not only it takes
away any potential Knight d4 jumps
because that would just lose a pawn but
it also forces this knight back to e7
should be too mean takes me to 9 g7 and
that is again an unhappy fianchettoed
Knight rogue d1 just over defending that
d5 square again you see who's happy now
White is happy because he has all them
pawns in the center Feeny seven and
Queenie salmon just doesn't really feel
right because it runs into rook e1 and
any time there'll be EF Knight F force
will come to the temple and the Queen
will be in danger
rook e8 and it's time to get a more
bigger bite of the cake and he gets f4 n
not only does he have all those pawns he
also takes away this important epub
square from black so from a theoretical
perspective and the positional
perspective White's position is just
much much better I even dare say winning
rook d8 and again let's try to channel a
bit of cran expositional excellence you
already have a really nice position
but can we pinpoint a piece that is a
little bit still awkward it needs to be
regrouped can you find the piece and the
move in this position for white
yeah obviously this night on e - is
super awkward so going to c3 is just
perfect now the bishop might not be
ideal however it does its duty of
defending both the d5 and the e4 pawns
which is perfect Knight c1 the problem
at night c1 it doesn't really have a
perspective now if you was to say night
C 193 night after night g4 Knight f6 you
are either a genius or you have all of
the time on this planet but probably you
really don't because they'll just play
h5 and this whole journey was for
nothing
however after Knight c3 there is a big
plant that Kramnik is playing for namely
he wants to get his Knight to e4 and if
that happens it is a game over as soon
as this night lands on f6 there is not
much you can do about it it's gone
you know if six trying to stop white
from jumping around but can you stop
Vladimir Kramnik from playing like a
technician in 2020 I doubt it
he 5 he goes all-in doesn't care about
the pawn he just wants to get that
Knight to e4 de 94 not only hitting the
queen but activating the Queen as well
on b2 prenup in b5 f e now Queenie 5 is
something that comes with a parental
advisory of Knight f6 check and your
queen is falling if you take on f6 Queen
takes f6 and that's all you're down a
queen and losing shahrukh takes e5
played here
and it is white to move and when and
just a reminder in chess if you find a
winning move try to find a move that
wins even more
exactly so Knight f6 seems to be winning
however the dastardly rook F 1 is much
much better and obviously kramnik when
he saw Knight f6 he probably said no no
no no I'm trying to win your queen
instead because if you go in that f6
Queen f6 Queen e5 probably you're
winning however nothing as good as
winning a whole rook or the Lady of
Queen h5 then yes you save the rook on
e5 however Knight f6 and that family
fork is going to hurt and again if you
move the Queen anywhere else let's say
just c8 for example Queen takes e5 and
you're down a rook and no compensation
so Brooke f1 so neppo had to go for
broke and take on e4 but as we all know
that is not a good sign it's already
kind of lost for NAPA me ah she takes
takes Queen f6 rook d7 rook e1 when
you're up material you exchange 98 Mina
3 forcing the exchanges takes takes 96
Queen up six and one of those things
that I learned just recently whenever
you are having a winning position make
sure you don't take your foot from the
gas you still have to go for mate you
still have to play like you don't have
the advantage and b7 and here comes our
favorite move if you're a bent Larsen
fan you would know which move I'm
talking about
so it's Kramnik to play and play bent
Larsen's favorite March try to find it
it is actually remarkable
age for the pawn marches up to age six
and sets up this beautiful 86 Queen g7
mating concept h4 played h5 can you stop
Kramnik from attacking no you can't g4
just breaking it open H takes and
marches on the Larsen pawn it's going to
eight six I mean if you think I check
you and take stuff and you're just
losing King eight seven
kingi to Knight f5 takes takes and the
rook shows up on h1 with deadly threats
and it's checkmate
it woke h8 so this was one of those
kramnik games where he actually showed
his positional side and he said nah I'm
just kidding I'm going in for the attack
he 594 and rook F one rook F 1 is
actually probably the most elegant
solution there even though probably not
f6 would have won as well but talking
about more of a tactical but original
way of playing let's take a look at this
game between the azan sev and Kramnik
and in this game
it starts off slow he plays this funky
little move of c3 I don't advise you to
do this it's not a good move
probably he wanted to push it twice but
they said ah c3 will be fine c6 Bishop
f4 g6 and we get into this very standard
sort of position Bishop e2 97 now if
this would be played in let's say 2010
you'd say and guess chronics next move a
hundred percent it's gonna be castles
and
play positionally however me write the
date 20 20 20 and kramnik is on a
totally different planet
so it is for you dear viewer to actually
channel your inner chronic and make this
fairly slow position exciting go
yep so one of those big deals in this
position is the following everything is
kind of tedious and fairly boring
however that Bishop went from CA to f5
and Kramnik spots that and says hey what
are you going to do with that Bishop not
much if you go back by g5 and after
taking on e6 that is a positional
advantage for white for sure and this is
probably an easy position for Kramnik to
play so G for Bishop e4 this is not the
end of the story
if Ria's onself could get away with
Knight takes e4 Knight takes e4 probably
the equilibrium would still stay but
he's already playing like 2020 kramnik
goes g5 the point being if you move the
night away I take on e4 de 92 and not
only do I have the bishop pair I also
have a target on e4 which more likely
than not gonna win
so g5 Bishop takes f3 was a must as
played by intensive Bishop f3 98 or
second tabia position so kramnik did
succeed in achieving to get the bishop
pair against the knights so it's already
sort of unbalanced but your chromic
you're not quite satisfied yet what move
would satisfy Kramnik swish to make this
they gain super sharp and exciting
and the move is h4 he says okay you
don't have a knight on f6 anymore to
defend your king side some just gonna
throw pawns atcha and try to checkmate
'if I've a very nice move by area son
sev if your opponent is playing on the
flank you strike in the mid in the
center now here comes the big question
do we take on e5 yes we have the bishops
we would love to have those bishops have
some open diagonals not here not at all
ship g3 the reason he doesn't take
because Knight takes e5 even Bishop e5
makes sense why because in this case
black would get rid of White's bishop
pair and these Knights would get some
juicy outposts on e4 and c4 this would
be a pretty brilliant position for black
to play and noticing that these Knights
are not really that active at the moment
he says no no no you do you I'm not
gonna help you get these Knights closer
to these outposts ninety six anyways
getting closer to these nice outposts on
f5 and c4 Bishop g4 and even though
Kramnik is bent on playing aggressive
chess he still notices when there are
positional ideas so he's stopping Knight
f5 from happening and if that would
happen he would just snap it off the
board and be happy because that pawn
would become a weakness and a target for
the ladies so here takes takes Queen f3
and that pawn would be a target for the
Queen so rook e8 noticing that the king
is in the center rook e8 and that looks
annoying
however kramnik
does not panic and place this little
move of Queen f3 the point is the
following if you take on d4 there's
still a knight hanging on d6
so you still can't do this so summing up
he get the bishop pair some targets he
is threatening to open up the position
with h5 however what will be chronic
snack smooth and one of those things are
very important in chess if you play a
move it is advised for you to know what
will be your next move so what is
Kramnik planning to do after Queen f3
so if you just think with chess
principles in mind white is trying to
play on the flanks so black is trying to
strike in the mid or the center and if
your opponent is trying to attack you in
the center what do you want to do with
your king
you want to evacuate castlelong
you want to get out of the way of that
danger might be six defending that d6
night but just in the nick of time
kramnik gets to castle and as we talked
before kramnik 2020 we are going for
checkmates Knight c4 Knight takes Knight
takes so the reason he takes on c4 is
the following he really wants to get rid
of that night also this d2 Knight is not
doing that much so it's a good exchange
Knight takes c4 and seeing that there
could be some danger of it Queen b6 and
that Queen and night combo can be
annoying he drops back with the Queen
just over defending the b2 upon a five
mean c2 so if I show you this structure
of eat egg C takes d4 what does this
remind you structurally or opening Weiss
what opening does this look like and
that's very important by the way because
it helps you you know guide yourself and
know what can possibly happen in this
type of position
can you call this a King's Indian type
of position Grunfeld a qgd maybe
it is definitely more like a qgd
sometimes surprisingly enough you get
similar positions into Grunfeld but one
of those big deals in the calls bad / qg
d so queen's gambit accepted positions
is the following oftentimes black is
going to try to attack you however nine
times out of ten white won't get
checkmated so that is a good news for a
kramnik hey for bus plates is trying to
push the pawn up to a3 Bishop e2 just
attacking the knight b5 d e now de is
sort of releasing the tension and also
trying to eliminate that intruder on c4
should be 5 takes takes and here comes a
very nice defensive idea by kramnik try
to find it first off what is black
threatening a black is really
threatening to go either before or a3 we
really need to find a defensive idea to
stop that from ever happening and if we
do black attack is probably just gonna
run out of steam
did he have to switch to defense well he
felt it safest to first defend and then
see if he has an attack yep obviously a
three the easiest way to stop your
opponent from playing a three this if
you play a three yourself mean e7 and
King b1 is that your typical Sicilian
move just running away from any
potential trickery if the C file was to
open up anytime in the future
rook e8 Bishop d3 just pressing on that
a g6 pawn also just hinting at the idea
of h5 96 ruk h3 and again this is
typical kramnik he doesn't rush with the
h5 break even if you could play it he
prepares this onslaught first and then
he goes for h5 or be not worried about
95 93 not really unless there's a
tactical idea behind it you don't really
care about these manoeuvres 96 rook h3
c5 and now this is actually getting a
bit more dangerous with b4 as but Ryazan
sev will try to open it up on the
beefed-up but as I mentioned to you
before this will look a lot like a cause
bad structure where white usually
doesn't get checkmated so it's not gonna
happen here either
rook h1 just doubling on the hb4 a bee
queen a4 be a queen takes a three why
doesn't a wide get checkmate it well as
you can see it has a queen defending the
b2 upon a bishop close by and in two
moves a rookie can help out and eight in
the defense so I just have way more
defenders than black has attackers and
that's the reason why my chances of
surviving an attack is higher
than being made it would be eight also
to talk about the fact that he goes age
five now and H thinks g6 is just very
strong if that ever happens let's say
takes H takes is brutal
you can't even capture back because ruk
h8 and you lose the b8 rook so you've
got to go for some desperado andrea's on
Sep does so and enter the endgame Queen
e7 very nice little touch and as I told
you you never get into trouble in these
calls bad structures Frug b2 king c1 and
if rook e7 there's Bishop c4 and the
rook is falling you do not have time to
pin me because you've got to treat that
rook rook e7 Bishop c4 DC age takes F G
and here comes the big question here
comes the big question how to continue
in this position
detect clearly petered out there's not
much going to happen over there so you
must switch gears now in this position
yep Brooksie one is an idea at four so
we're clearly in the endgame correct and
if that is so you're still deep in the
NEA which one is the strongest piece of
all the King so let's just bring this
king up not only bother that c-pawn
actually might come handy when we want
to play for our force yeah rook b7 King
c3 now if black would take on b2 that
would leave this H pawn on three and
thus King would be very much in danger
so rook c8 was played instead rook h4 so
white is actually a king up as this King
is just stuck there defending the h7
pawn
while this King is fighting like a true
warrior rugby three kings c2 now again
you've got to treat that pawn because
Ruby five saying giving up the pawn
which is kind of strange but at this but
here instead of taking kramnik decides
to just keep the rook here on g4
defending the pawn and attacking the c-4
guy rook b8 will be one so it's just
saying hey in the long run you lose the
C pawn and I'll have the passer and you
have nothing to brag about as black rook
there Luke c4 king c3 now just a
reminder this whole charity event was
actually an a blitz format so they
didn't have like oceans of time to
figure out things so this seems like a
very nice practical choice by Kramnik he
says I don't want to risk my advantage
I really just want to use this pawn as a
way to win the game
rogue g5b 4 and this is an ideal concept
he has a rope supporting this pawn and
the rook behind the pawn not even
talking about the fact that there's a
king around that is very useful and
you're in a mid of a rock and pawn and
gay Luke f3 rookie for not giving pawns
for free and also cutting off the king
from ever getting close to that b7
square
mind you if result of could get that
king to b7 there'd be good chances of
holding but that's just a dream in this
position it's unlikely to happen
rugby 5 and here you can see the king
advantage but is ready to play king c4
just driving that rook away will be 6 b5
ok 5 just trying to cut off the king so
there's no more king c5 moves but here
again why it plays that typical move
that you should be able to fight
whenever in your and the endgame studies
that's why to move and play try to find
Kramnik next move
so if you found the idea of getting a
rook on the seventh rank congratulations
that's where your rook belongs to rook
East seven you get your rook over there
and you will be hinting at some back
rank checkmates after that not only you
caught the king again I can't really
move around that otherwise he'll lose
the pawn but also you set up a second
threat which is so important age five
now he doesn't go for this instead he
goes for rook c7 and plans to get rid of
this blockade er and once that blockade
is gone the b-pawn is just going to
Queen h4 rook c6 takes takes King g7 so
it is on cells less hope is to give up a
rook for the C pawn and one with his own
pawns c7 rook F to sneak your little
trick if you queen you'll turn out to be
sad as you lose the Queen with rook see
to check
however he has this nice little move of
king d3 taking away all these squares
from the rook it had to go back and
after rook b8 black resigned because
there's no way you can stop white from
promoting to a queen after rook f8 and
promotion so what we kind of learned
from this game is yes it is good to
attack but if you have a better King and
hanging hey that's the end game you want
to play just like me seen in this game
between Kramnik and Ria's on SEF so last
but not least let's take a look at
another classic from this event and that
is played between kramnik and there was
champion ship Challenger
Kuryakin c4 Knight f6 good old English
five please this d3 and this is
something you would call sort of the
rouser Sicilian that reversed colors d5
takes takes e4 in browsers usually you
see III but II for is a normal move in
these positions as well I'd have six
ships e5 this should be three if any of
you are familiar with Sicilians this is
basically wise playing a Sicilian
defense but up a tempo and then they'll
see if that's enough for something h3 so
the five fight usually is revolving
around d4 square so kramnik plays h4 so
there won't be Bishop g4 ideas and if
you go an ID for you still have to tend
for this e5 pump castles castles rook e8
rook c1 now Knight d4 ideas don't really
work yet because takes well if you take
with the e pawn white can't go night a4
and possibly have a little advantage
because of this protected pawn and if
you take Bishop d4 Knight d4 you can't
take the Queen because there's not b5
hitting the Queen and the c7 and then
you're probably gonna get forth pretty
soon so the study plays h6 a3
we should be six he maneuvers the night
to c5 again we're back to maneuvering
kramnik 90 for Queen these six nights e5
and this is actually pretty annoying
because you wouldn't want to give up
that Bishop because if you do not only
does why have the bishop pair he is
probably going to push you off the board
on the Queen side as well so here Corey
Aachen played the sad move Bishop c8
which is not good
and it doesn't look pretty either before
a six just trying to stop be five mean
c29 age five and as Kramnik decided that
hey I have the advantage here I do not
need to go for any complications he
didn't go for the move maybe he missed
it we do not know but here is the chance
for you to shine as it has white to move
and he has a splendid little tactical
idea here try to move and play
grandma guys she didn't play it
so here in this position why it has this
brilliant idea of Knight takes e5 which
is outstanding because yeah you tagged
that night however I could take with the
Queen take the rook both will defend
that h5 night however it turns out after
f4 there's nothing you can do about it
you go not f4 Bishop f4 and you have
some issues and if you go here counter
attacking F takes e5 comes the tempo on
the Queen and you don't have time to
take on f1 so incredible as it may seem
this Knight takes e5 f4 idea would have
given kramnik a big advantage even at
move 17 but okay as I told you as before
kramnik if he has the advantage doesn't
really like to go into tactical
adventures unless he is pretty sure that
everything is going his way or at least
that was his style in the early days
Queen f6 and he gets the coveted d4 move
and as you might know if you get d4 in
the Sicilian doesn't matter which color
you are you're probably gonna be better
especially if you're up a tempo before
he takes Knight takes d4 so not only
does black have lots of pieces still
sitting in the garage that e8 rook c8
bishop and rookin e8 he also doesn't
have any central control and that's a
problem not even talking about that
night on H 594 should be for me g5
now here Kramnik plays this very nice
move of Bishop takes h5 just eliminating
any sorts of counter play that car yeah
ken could have in this position ship h5
h5f three yes it does come at a cost of
losing the bishop however in this
position with that bishop still being
stuck there defending that b7 pawn this
is fairly Pleasant for Kramnik a5 queen
f2 a Bab green g6
King h1 so with this solid centre he is
in no rush to show his intentions
actually waiting for Kuryakin to show
his intentions c6 and kremlings next
move is again showing some great
understanding so get your positional
rush ready and try to find what the big
blood play in this position
in fact it's not that hard to find if
you kind of anticipate blacks next move
but obviously is trying to get more
space than he had before
he plays this remarkable move of G for
now g4 would be frowned upon everywhere
on the planet if it wasn't really played
by Kramnik however this move has a great
point
black wanted to play f5 so if you just
Billy dally with Roxy for there's gonna
be f5 and if these bishops actually
activate there'll be some counter
chances for setting a Kuryakin however
after g4 there is no more breaks for
black and one of those things that
Kramnik does best is to kill his
opponents counter play so g4 is just an
amazing move by kramnik ro K 3 and now
they played the move suggested by you
your chat row k1 just getting rid of the
active rook on a3 again he is just
trying to smother that Bishop on c8 and
making sure that Kuryakin doesn't get
any sort of counter play okay one bishop
takes a 1 f6 now again Kuryakin also
sees that this bishop is awful least
strong that is it's pretty strong
si decides just to block it up kingi too
can slowly slowly improving ship c7
Bishop c3 h5 Queen h4 probably h5 even
though visually appealing it has a
problem it actually opens up the
situation for a white so the best idea
for Kuryakin would have been just to sit
and wait and see what white is going to
do because white is still far far away
from actually breaking through in the
center however that's probably crammed
thanks go he played h5 and
to create shorties actually at the
dilemma if you take you open up the
position for my rook and queen and I
might actually intrude with your bishops
just shot out of the action which is
going to happen on the H file so cardiac
indecisive play b6 instead and just wait
it out 93 in f7 Queen takes h5 saying
okay a pawn is a pawn and might help me
to win the game Queen takes age 5 GH
King age 7 probably cardiac and
evaluated this position as being good I
have the bishop there what can possibly
go wrong I'm just going to go King h6
King takes age 5 and have a fantastic
position however the big Vlad calculated
further than that can you spot that Amir
chronics next move and probably that
move was what clinched the game for
kramnik
so the problem child here is the h5 pawn
question is how can white fight against
intrusions by that King on h7
I mean Bishop d2 makes sense however you
do give away the D file you don't want
to give away the default so I'll be
honest with you kramnik didn't quite
stop it however he came up with a really
nice tactical defense he went Knight f2
he's planning to go Knight g4 so what
really has to go King age six Nagi Tech
now if you take take and light is just
up a pawn and completely winning but
what happens if black takes on a h5
boom Bishop takes f6 and that's a very
nice sacrifice probably miss by car
yakin normally there would be Bishop
takes g4 and taking on f6 but oh it's a
check you've got to move your king and I
moved back even so here you can even
take on g7 check and then the whole
house with rook d7 so that is a cute
little double sacrifice of Bishop f6 and
Bishop takes g7 probably well spotted by
crown neg they're probably in advance
see when the King h7 but that does not
help you Bishop takes f6 and this is the
double trick takes takes GF rook d7
check and you lose the bishop so even
here Bishop f6 works I didn't talk about
G takes f6 at all but the reason I
didn't talk about it because it's a fork
we've got to move the King and I take c8
now this tragedy would be compounded if
you go King g7 because you would run
into another fork which would be kind of
uncomfortable submission of f6 was
played Bishop e6 and this happy bishop
moves back to c3 c5 you're up upon so
you're happy to exchange BC BC and h6 if
you take there's again that f6 and
you're getting forked so that's kind of
annoying ship G for a G King takes h6
and surprise surprise the bishop strikes
again the ship takes g7 King takes g7
then there's route d7 same old story
your Bishop is gonna be a goner and it's
gonna be two pawns indeed king g6
the ships III just making sure
everything's defended there's no reason
to keep this Bishop on pre there will be
8 e 5 start rolling those pawns Ruby 3
rook see one just over defending C 4 F 4
and these tanks are just starting to
roll there's not much you can do about
this as black it should be six you still
have to be careful by the way King f3
Bishop a5 and it's you who lose so even
in a winning position you've got to stay
vigilant ecigs Bishop e3 trying to be a
nuisance but f5 check does come in time
King g5 rook see to king g4 f6 and these
pawns are near unstoppable ship g5 e 7
rugby 8 rookie - and f7 and it is not
much that black can do here
he could have safely resigned but
probably but both being in time trouble
they play it on Queens rook c2 Queen c8
mean takes c4 and basically the game is
over
kingi to gate 6 in d3 this is just
winning we should be 5 in cornering the
king and asking where are you going to
bring that broke if you go rogue do you
want mean after they check and I take
your rook ok 6 but that's not gonna fare
any much better
you need seven just a little bit of
repetition Bishop d4 so there's no side
checks
rokay - Bishop e3 okay for King f3 and
there's no defense against the big
threat of Queen 2 XG 5 so here
Sergei karyakin resigned a very nice
game by Kramnik
and as you can see 2020 Kramnik is the
modern Kramnik so if you loved his chess
stay in tune because probably he's going
to play more rapid inlets in the future
and we hope to see some more fireworks
with that I really hope you enjoyed this
lecture and have a great day or night
there ever you are
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]